hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every Tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com or twitch on TV for estas
gamespot if you're watching live special
thanks all y'all listening to this on
your podcast machines make sure you rate
subscribe do all that stuff I don't know
what's going on I'm sitting here on the
lobby set though this week week of all
weeks the 20th anniversary of gang spot
com sitting across the table from two
people who are way cleverer than me at
this mr. Peter Brown reviews editor hi
and you're the person you are cosplaying
as specifically I kevin kevin van or the
previous reviews editor here at gamespot
com you were just passing by the office
I was actually yes when I was little I
was literally out walking and I sent a
text to Peter saying oh I sent a text to
Peter saying hey I'm so so I got a new
job but I'm gonna be leaving at some
point like to a faraway place leaving
leaving yeah leaving leaving and I
wanted to make sure to you know things
are really busy and hectic and I wanted
to stop by and just make sure that I got
a chance to see gamespot peeps before I
suddenly just disappeared yeah i'm at
the comment and Peter's like hey while
you're here why don't you do this thing
and so I did the thing and then you do
my job from you for two hours sure and
then Danny's Danes like hey can you
stick around for the lobby and it's like
like I got anything else yet the minute
you leave here there's gonna be some of
us roping you into something which is
fine which is fine i love being back
this is actually my first time since
you've changed floors white but I've
that I am and I've seen y'all but I
haven't been in the building building
yeah well since you since you moved july
of last year yeah july last year so i
guess it's perfect you're here because
we wanted to have a section too bad
gamespot's 20th birthday and you've been
here longer than the most of us here I
think maybe I was here no geez you have
almost nine nine years all right and so
before we sort of get to the past paso
I'll talk a little bit about what you've
been doing what have you been doing
since we've seen you last because you've
got a whole new adventure coming up in
the next couple of months but i already
had adventures before that yeah so I
when I first I mean when I left gamespot
I i went to trion worlds i was first
working there on the game called
pavilion
which I hope everybody plays but we
localized Evillene we did not develop
tively and we'd we localized Evillene at
tryon and so most of my job was spent
writing writing writing writing lots and
lots of words right and at that point
when when that sort of finished when
that part of the localisation finished I
moved over to the Alice reactor team as
a designer and so I did a lot of stuff
with Alice reactor which is awesome and
you should all play it when it's when
it's widely available and hopefully the
people that played the free steam
weekend I'm sorry I'm shouldn't be
pimping [ __ ] away I mean I'm presumably
we're not paying you for coming on the
lobby so you know I'm not being paid for
doing here so so I did that and then and
then since then I've been working with a
with an indie team cleaver soft and we
are making a a platformer with dragons
all right on earth night which is also
really great but I have nothing more I
can really share about that since we
don't have a release day we don't have
like there's a sunny exclusive I can say
that much we already know that it's a
you know ps4 Vita I mean what are you
doing on that one well I'm a designer
design looks so how does that because I
know obviously you were like prolific
writer here yeah I computer can attest
to the fact that when you read your work
position you spend a lot of the time
smashing on keyboards so presumably it
was like oh that's a good fit you're
going somewhere else to write web games
how did this shift into design happen
and what like what element of design you
working on cuz I'm completely ignorant
of had this stuff well I mean there's a
lot of stuff that goes in design and so
so I'll give you an example on Alice
reactor when I was with with trying
working on Alice reactors that involved
level design so if you liked the second
map I design a second so that was so
that was great on Alice reactor but I
also did things like writing character
scripts and voiceover sessions and oh I
doing things dealing with the
progression scheme things dealing with
monetization that was apparently all
through out the window since the game
went to pay pay to play rather than
free-to-play and things like that so
that's what I that's sort of a
jack-of-all-trades right on Alice
reactor deville ian was basically
writing writing writing writing for
cleaver soft most of what i'm doing is
also level design which is a bit
different
it's a 2-d game a 2d platformer so I
spent a lot of days doing things like
what some people do with like super
mario maker so I'm just basically taking
all of our assets and tools and trying
to keep them consistently fresh and
interesting and doing new things with
with the platforming is sort of what I'm
what I'm doing right now after nine
years of writing about games what's it
like nine months out of us doing all
this crazy stuff well I mean I miss you
guys but luckily I've had the chance to
do some stuff here and there and I'm
even working on some stuff for Peter now
I'm sort of maybe my final hurrah I
don't know like I thought journey would
be the you know journey on ps4 will be
the last the last thing I have a row for
gamespot not that got proven wrong
really just fed up with so a bombshell
was my first review after that and as
you probably know I dislike bombshell
with a great passion yes so but then I
mean I've gotten then to play like I got
to review hyper light drifter so I went
straight from a 2 to 12 and 9 well there
was something in between I forget what
it was I never know when we were there
was amazing between I don't know but
it's working on Witcher 3 blood and wine
yeah for you guys as well as the odin
sphere HD you reviewed Witcher 3 as well
I did read from the original which three
it was my purse again dear just I'm
gonna ten at a ten spot where you left
yeah you know me I mean in the end I
guess I gave out three while I was in
Kim's Metal Gear Solid 4 cyl for Witcher
3 and journey journey on ps4 which in my
mind is probably one of the most perfect
games I mean if you think of a tennis
perfect which I don't but if you do
think of a tennis perfect i think that's
one of the most deserving games i can
think of that to be given a 10-hour game
of year in 2012 and also mary's favorite
game of the past 20 years as in our one
of our many features were put together
this week on gamespot celebrating 20
years and he of the website 20 years a
long long time at will talk about what
you what's coming up on your next
adventure yeah in a little bit but
that's let's get a little bit wide eyed
nostalgic a little bit here Peter when
did you like when did you join games
because for me you've been here like
forever you're like part of them as a
staff member you mean yeah yeah to first
start writing a big well for gamespot
that was october two thousand eleven
maybe november i was working as a cook
in Texas trying to get freelance writing
as much as possible and I got a job
opened up for a job reading strategy
guides writing spot I lied about my
address I reached into my my well of
references which was Curtis said he used
to work here who I worked with at 1up
com back in the day and spent all my
money flying out here and and have since
learned that I probably didn't have to
lie about living in California but say
like number 10 second street besides its
kind I had a friend who was like okay
man yeah you can use my address but I
mean you know bottom line was I had
lived here before Texas and I could have
come back so I was well prepared for the
journey but not prepared for I think how
big of an impact gamespot his head of my
life right um I worked in a place called
want calm which I'm sure like people
remember and just stand the street here
yeah yeah literally like two blocks away
and that was a really special time for
me but nothing has really left its mark
like gamespot has me and I you know I
people try to know they talk about a
work-life balance and even like my close
friends try to you know persuade me to
maybe work less but I think they don't
understand that like this is kind of
like it it's threaded into me now like
gamespot is my life for better I don't
want to say for worse I mean sometimes
it's a job and jobs are stressful but
gamespot has been a positive force in my
life yeah yeah you feel like you sort of
got a lot of responsibility when you got
your ticket on the plane Kevin you came
from a sort of a similar place to me but
long long before me in fact when you got
hired it made me feel a lot you know
sort of hopeful for my chances you came
from the community I did I was a
moderator for years on the gamespot
forums and at some point I started just
writing for mom and I was always writing
re reviews and things like that too but
I was a moderator on the forms for a
while and then I started writing for
gamespy another place you might have
heard about yeah along with one but I
was I wasn't employed by gamespy but I
was I was a freelance free games by in
addition to doing writing for a site
that now doesn't exist in the form that
it used to mmm
for free just just for the fun of it and
I got a call out of the blue from Judy
Robinson who was in community of the
time and there was this position for a
tournament coordinator and I was the
first person they thought of so it's not
like I had applied for a position I just
got a call hmm and they said hey why
don't you come out an interview for this
position was like okay and so the
company put me on a plane and bra me
from from where I was living at the time
i was living in maryland working in
virginia and they loo me out for a job
interview that didn't feel like a job
interview at all it felt like gamespot
trying to sell itself to me which was
the strangest thing so I said okay I'll
completely change my life and I'll move
to I'll move to California yeah and I
left life behind and so that's what I
did and then nine years later I was
still doing it and you know i loved it i
mean you know like peter said it's a job
it's not as you know but but it's weird
when sort of life and leisure inert want
like work and leisure intertwines in a
way that they can do in the games
industry but it was time you know
sometimes you just have all this
creativity and you realize it's time to
use in a new way all right so that's
that's kind of what i did it wasn't
really what it wasn't because i wanted
to escape gamespot or anything I mean
nine years designed to you know i wanted
i wanted to do new things but i wanted
him to be with games because i love
games so much and and i wanted to put my
money where my mouth was and in a way
and say hey I okay i can write about
them but let's let's see what happens
when I make them now I mean I feel like
jumping into the sort of you know into
the unknown is something that if you
were to ask you know he's only three of
us here if you'd ask anyone who's
outside you know working of reduction or
out on the floor or even all the people
who've left you know in the past coming
years and that's like sort of the
ubiquitous tail is like most of the
people who work for this site and even
kind of want to think about IJ and down
the road it's it tends to be people who
have traveled far and sort of left
everything and left all their their
their family and people they knew before
for like a brand-new life I mean it
never kind of feels like you had any
other choice to do it because trying to
break into this industry is like such a
difficult like so much of it involves
time and place even even everyone should
get in yeah I take an opportunity where
you can there's there's no
you know when it when it comes up you do
it because you love it and because
there's no guarantee than anything else
is going to come up and that happens on
both sides of things I mean certainly in
game development right my time at tryon
was cut short for you know by just the
kinds of things that happen in in the
business of making games in the business
of reporting on games it's just that
cycle and so you you take what you can
when you can get it if it's the right
thing I mean there are certain things
that I viously i'm not going to do but
you know when you know when these when
these opportunities came up so yeah you
got to do it otherwise I'm just gonna be
saying for the rest of the time what
would have happened if I hadn't if I if
only I had done it I wonder what life
would be well now I get to know and as
it turns out it's pretty great and we
got a bunch of lovely comments in here
team toaster saying Kevin's Assassin's
Creed 1 review was the thing that made
me follow games swap back in 2007 Wow
nobody ever said that about that real
people that was one of my so you know
there's a long history of course of
reviewers getting hatred from you know
whatever know who knew but I mean the
earliest gamespot that really started
happening was with a command and conquer
3 review which we ifit's bull because it
wasn't that long after Supreme Commander
had come out right um and I scored come
in and conquer 3 higher than Jason
ocampo had scored last week about her
too Supreme Commander want one yeah and
so that was kind of the first time I
ever had people kind of whining at me
for something but Assassin's Creed is
also another interesting one because of
course I reviewed both that in the
original mass effect and I actually gave
Assassin's Creed a higher score than I
did the original mass effect and that
that haunted me for for quite a while I
stand by that and I still stand by
assassins creed one as still the the
assassins creed iya stuff Assassin's
Creed in the sense that it's the game
when you you're most like an assassin so
in that series so so yeah I totally
still love Assassin's Creed one to this
day and when you think about the sort of
I guess before you worked here what can
you remember any like reviewers or shows
or like any things you ever sort of
Rover wat or read or watched on gamespot
before that made you interested to work
on the side gamespot was always kind of
present as I like trolled the internet
looking
for things that magazines didn't provide
to me right back during the days of
dial-up screenshots yeah but I think
different from you guys i wasn't really
like a hardcore fan to said right when I
showed up here for whatever reason I
don't know it's not like I didn't like
the content you know but I'm I'm so
focused i think on at least in the past
anyway it's different now but in the
past I was so focused on like hyper like
Japanese console games and stuff like
that and GameSpot always had the it
seemed to have the pc audience more in
mind yeah sort of more mature games and
that was all well and good but it wasn't
when I was looking for but then when I
when I got here I was just like blown
away by the character of everyone on the
team their skill and how they made me
think about games differently I mean I
thought I knew things about games then
but I it's it's incredible the amount of
learned since I began here um yeah was
it you that sent me an email um maybe it
was somebody sent me an email not so
long ago about you know about reviews
and things on the site that I thought
were interesting from the last 20 years
because the cause of course the
anniversary was coming up and I've been
robbed and maybe it was robbed and and I
got and it was interesting like when I
once I started going through all the
things that made me love gamespot before
I'd even come here I was really
surprised like it not surprised I guess
but I was just like oh my god I can't
forget about this but I also can't
forget about this and for me Greg
kassahun was always of course the big
gun when it came to sort of who I looked
up to a game spot because it was
thoughtful but it was also funny and
nerdy and and just sort of you know I
felt a connection with Greg in terms of
what we liked and things like that and
you know maybe and I think it was things
like neverwinter nights his review of
that there was Andrew parks hysterical
gods and generals video review which is
still my favorite video review because
it exists from gamespot I mean everybody
looks to big rigs and write out review
is a classic but I really do think
Andrew parks gods and generals reviews
the reviews you know it kind of stands
on its own but I mean pretty much
anything greg did but there's also a
review that I don't think anybody even
knows on the site that was one of the
biggest for me and that's Ryan Davis's
project snowblind review
um that was I mean notwithstanding the
fact that I had a huge crush on Ryan
Davis hi there there was all there was
just you know that review was also one
of my and still is one of my favorites
on gamespot and I don't think anybody
even really knows that review it it
almost seems like a lot of great words
spent on a game that nobody thinks about
anymore but so much I mean although it
was the people that I loved and they
seem to be writing to two tastes that I
had that was always that was the reason
number one why I wanted to be here I
never actually thought you know you
think you know I'm thinking in 2002
while wouldn't it be neat if I win a
spot you know you don't think that for
years later that fact that thing is
actually going to be happening yeah do
you ever like three four years ago you
crack some joke to me in the hallway
about me having your job one day I
thought that was the most absurd notion
no I don't remember that I didn't you
probably wouldn't but at the time I was
like that's crazy but I saw I said that
to everybody 00 ever say it was like
please will somebody take this job right
but I i don't know i think we're talking
about i'm sorry i didn't mean to
overwhelm the cover stories now I mean
not like yeah like I remember being back
home and watching on the spot in Ireland
like seven years ago and to think that
like so much of your life gets impacted
by you know joining a place like this
it's it's really crazy we're very very
lucky i speaking of your sort of your
admiration for Greg kassav and you have
had a similar sort of post life post
review a in a sense yeah journalist life
and let's talk a bit about what you're
doing next cuz that's about yeah that's
a bit of a jump it is it is a bit of a
jump so it's it's been a little tough to
make happen because well I mean you'll
see why in a second so I'm joining
Larian Studios the the people that make
divinity original send the entire
divinity series so if you know if you
know divine divinity in all games that
came came after that then you know
Larian Studios so but for me it's a
dream come true in a lot of ways number
one is because Tiffany original sin was
my game of the year yeah here remember
um so you know yeah and it's it's like
again looks like the other thing or it's
like you don't actually think you know
it's not like when that happens like oh
maybe someday I'll get to actually work
with Larian Studios you know you don't
think that's gonna happen but yeah it
looks like an about as soon as I can get
all the rest of the paperwork in order
yeah because they're not in Sacramento
are they go now they're in Belgium so so
in about a month I'll be moving to ghent
belgium which which will be really
awesome and it's very frightening but
I'm really excited to see what comes
next and they've been really good to me
the whole the whole company just seems
really great and they've been really
patient seeing if the paperwork happens
is really hard as it happens to get you
know you got to get your work papers you
can't just I can't just move to another
country and say a meadow which is what
they say it's how they say hello and
Belgium actually is nao yes no you know
it's late you can't yeah you can't just
show up and decide you're gonna work
there's a there's a lot of government
rigmarole and and somebody on Twitter
said to me that you know this is just to
prepare me for how much Europeans love
red tape oh yeah for sure so it looks
like I'll be having some some red tape
red tape in the future with your palm
freeze yeah Paul yeah which is weird
because now I'm moving to a land most
well known for for chocolate waffles and
beer now now that I'm now that I'm
vegetarian and I'd lost all this weight
i had lost 119 things like that so we'll
see why on earth although to be fair a
beer and it's funny because I've never
really been a drinker so it's
interesting though Belgian against
specifically has every Thursday is that
is vegetables day really hearing day
that's so everybody on Thursdays that
lives in kenta's is inspired to eat
their vision it's gonna be all weird
vegetables and I used to like Brussels
sprouts and turnips though well Brussels
is there so it made us attend they would
be in the Brussels geez Danny kno your
know your globe but it'll be interesting
and you know learning Flemish um
basically funny Dutch so that'll be fun
so this is a lot of stuff to get ready
for I'm really excited and I'm also
terrified utterly utterly terrified I
think I get what everybody would get to
it's like a huge change what if
something happens what if I'm not good
at it what didn't you know you you know
what if what if I have a heart attack
before I go and nothing ever and I
don't get to see it or get to do it or
or something like that what if the plane
crashes out of the sky and I don't get
to have this amazing opportunity you
know it's like that's but that's the way
I think that's my brow how weird my
brain is so but yeah that's that's kind
of what's happening next and you know
how long that lasts i don't know that's
the fun thing about fun and tariff
another terrifying thing about games
making about life about life fishers you
don't know what happens I mean I I had
no idea how long I'd be a try on but I
was hoping would be more than it was and
then again you know this is a really
financially strange industry so you
don't know what's gonna happen which is
why I'm trying to connect myself also
with as many any project site any
projects it's like Han because they're
on you know you get to you get to wear a
lot of hats too with those kinds of
things and you get to be part of you
know you get to be a bigger part of the
decision-making process and things like
that with smaller projects you know not
everybody gets to be like part of this
core indie team that just go you know
you not everybody gets to be double fine
and just kind of move from one project
to the next to just kind of be this
awesome unit you know there's a lot more
flux typically so anyway yeah that's
what's coming next so I'm excited um so
tivity original sin to 10 yeah yeah yeah
yeah now collusion you can say it to me
I'm not on the reviews to ya if I only
review it if it's a formative one games
I'm kidding of course I mean 11
incredible secret that nobody talks
about in the games industry is that game
developers know pretty much how good
their game is before or anybody else
Kepler is up um yeah and typically I'm
not the case every time but typically i
mean that's that's just the way it is so
you know I you know hope you all like
that was reactor 2 I already know how
much you like the villians I hope to
like every game I mean isn't that what
we all hope for yeah I mean you want
every game to be awesome some say yeah
that's the thing about every game I make
to be awesome if I'd a bunch of really
awesome was a sorority there's just more
it's not a fantastic here has already I
think you're doing an uncharted and
overwatch today Kevin thank you so much
for coming out we appreciate it nice to
have a lovely chat about the history of
get I guess the the sort of the past the
present and the future I mean that's
what websites are right it's just a
bunch of people who are contributing in
this
best way they can and contribute a leave
and next people come in and the wheel
keeps on spinning so yeah thank you so
much absolute Peter Brown hey we're
gonna ask you to stick around you got
five Kevin you don't know watch my
fallout at aldi you never think you
never pay for this is the man who
reviewed fallout 3 saw new thing he had
a chance to be funded for considering
you're working so much I didn't I I got
very close but I did not beat fallout 4
but honestly part of that has to do with
the fact that i don't like fallout 4 I
chava shooter it's too much of a shooter
I felt like a lot of choice has been
taken away from me and I have lots of
niggles I can't stand the way convert
the dialogue and conversation systems
working fallout 4 for example so I have
a lot of problems with the fallout 4 but
honestly I can go back and play new
vegas with mods anytime I want and so
you know I get that I can I can still
have the fallout experience that I love
and that's that's you know go back and
play fallout 2 or i can play wasteland 2
which is which is also fantastic so
again lots of lots of things to do if
one game doesn't meet your needs fair
thousands of that there are a bunch of
mr. Hadley want to combine here relieve
mr. van oort are you heading out right
now then I don't know what do you want
me to do I don't know if you're still
here in 30 minutes well I'll hang so you
and and hang out with people outside
alright cool and I guess Rob can take my
place for now it's he's much better
looking anyway add the chat all saying
lots of lots of good looks and thanks
for popping it saying thanks and
seriously I guess before I get up I'm
sorry Rob no no I know you're prettier
than I am but sometimes age before
beauty and but seriously you know as
much as I want to be fair to everybody
out there because I mentioned something
about you know you know reviewers get
hate a little while ago but I also want
to make sure that it's you know without
you I don't I wouldn't get to be get to
do what I had gotten to do and you know
as much as it gonna be hard to like deal
with kind of deluge of people that don't
like you and say nasty things to you I
did it day in day out because I loved it
because I hope that maybe somewhere out
there you know I could help other people
love it too and I in a in a different
way or to start to appreciate games and
in a new way in a in a thoughtful way
and over the years I got a chance to to
grow in that respect because I was
surrounded by writers that I admired and
people that made me look
games in different ways and I had before
and I hope that I got the chance to do
that for some people and whether or not
you you liked what I had to say or not I
hope that whoever was out there knew
that I did it with as much love and
passion and and certainly honesty and
it's easy to always you know nowadays
it's easy to just oh you know a
journalist suck and you know bias and so
forth and so on but you know we do it
because we love the games and because we
really do have something to say and hope
that what we have to say can have have
meaning for somebody and hopefully and
all of that somebody out there a few
people out there found found something
in that you gave it to me for sure I
hope so you definitely did and I you
know that's that's all I really want the
end is this for people to keep looking
at games in new ways and to keep looking
at that art form and saying you know
this is some of the things we've done
and we've got a lot more awesome things
to do yes I'm sure here's to the future
yeah thanks guys Rob all right coming to
my place you pretty early on that note
come on Kevin getting in here and making
us all well up don't worry that is
you've earned us you can do what you can
do you want that speech absolutely
seriously my first day I'm sorry so my
first day on I did [ __ ] like this all
the time Casa can do it can do an intro
I don't exist password I can